bonsoir bonsoir thierry mariani donc qui
rentre d'irak at samad moussaoui donc
vous avez 35 ans vous êtes professeur en
électrotechnique à montpellier vous êtes
le frère de zacarias moussaoui qui est
inculpé depuis décembre 2001 c'était le
premier inculpé par la justice
américaine pour les attentats du 11
septembre il est soupçonné d'avoir été
le 20e pirate aux ordres du réseau al
qaïda six chefs d'accusation pèsent
contre lui dont quatre sont passibles de
la peine de mort
le procès débutera le 6 janvier 2003 ce
verdict en plus est une véritable épée
de damoclès sur les relations franco
américaines puisque zacarias moussaoui
votre frère est de nationalité française
et qu'en france comme vous le savez
évidemment on a aboli la peine de mort
alors vous publiez zacarias moussaoui
mon frère chez denoël un pacte avec la
collaboration de la journaliste florence
boukila interview vérité alors le 13
septembre 2001 vous roulez sur le
plateau de milo entre mende et et
montpellier c'est jeudi
la semaine est finie la nuit tombe vous
écouter la radio france info
hélas dans l'immensité des cévennes vous
entendez une voix qui dit votre nom
moussaoui rue elle dit zacarias
moussaoui franco algérien a été arrêté
en relation avec les attentats du 11
septembre
depuis le 17 août et je crois qu'ils
avaient ajouté un prénom ahmed ou un
autre prénom
et puis disait franco-algérien donc ma
première réaction c'était de dire
zacarias moussaoui franco algériens vont
s'est passé par franco marocain puis il
disait à pire il ajouté il disait né à
saint jean de luz
donc là
ma gorge serrée et alors on va commencer
par le commencement votre père était
carreleur au maroc quand il a rencontré
votre mère qui à l'époque avait 14 ans
alors on n'a jamais su en fait si votre
mère avait voulu de toute force quitté
son foyer pour se marier avec votre père
ou au contraire si elle a été mariée de
force
ma mère dit qu elle a été mariée de
force ma grand mère dit que c'est elle
qui a voulu se marier
mon oncle dit que c'est elle qui a voulu
se marier ma tante dit que c'est elle
qui a voulu se marier il ya l'essentiel
n'est pas là
en tout cas c'est clair que des années
plus tard elle en a gardé une douleur et
une souffrance
elle s'en est largement exprimés
l'essentiel pour elle il est là en fait
c'est que ce mariage au départ c'était
une douleur pas pour elle alors deux
filles naissent et puis votre père
décide d'émigrer en france en 1965 sur
la côte basque et vous laissez vous donc
en 1967 et votre frère
zacharias en 1968 et trois ans après en
vos parents divorcent et vous partez
tous les deux avec votre mère à mulhouse
ou votre mère a trouvé du travail alors
pourquoi mulhouse
alors je ne sais pas j'étais trop jeune
je ne sais pas je sais qu'on s'est
retrouvé dans un dans un orphelinat qui
s'appelle le home saint jean oui parce
que votre mère peut pas vous gardez donc
mais à la dass j'imagine que ça doit
être des moments terribles pour elle et
c'est vrai que cet endroit pour nous
c'était un endroit un petit peu d'effroi
en même temps on était rassuré parce que
il y avait des parquets en bois il y
avait de gros et dreux dont il faisait
chaud c'était bien chauffé et en même
temps on était un petit peu effrayé
parce qu'on n'avait pas nos parents et
puis on voyait tous ces gens nous
disaient c'est un orphelinat
donc vous comprenez chaque jour comme si
on était des invités comme si on allait
partir demain 1
mais à chaque jour ont succédé annoncé
durer un an oui ça a duré plus d'un an
ça a marqué zacharias vous pensé cette
séparation de sa mère je pense que ça a
marqué toute la famille je pense que ça
a marqué toute la famille parce que dans
cet orphelinat je pense que c'est des
endroits un petit peu où il n'y a pas
d'autorité parentale dont les éducateurs
sa réponse par la famille en france pas
les parents
mais alors en plus quand votre père
vient vous voir vous partez en courant
parce que votre mère vous a expliqué que
votre père était un méchant qui lui ai
fait du mal
donc quand vous voyez votre père
s'approcher pour vous parler vous parti
en courant et d'ailleurs il finit par se
lasser
il vient plus et puis un jour votre mère
vous dis ben vous voyez vous a laissé
tomber ben oui c'est triste c'est pas
quelque chose mais c'est quelque chose
qu'on ne comprenait pas nous d'un côté
on avait notre mère qui ne disait que
qui nous montrait son affection qui nous
avec 6 rhdp de l'orphelinat pour nous
c'était c'est formidable c'était une
héroïne pour nous et puis là l'autre
côté on avait ce père qui était absent
et qui était accusé de tous les maux
donc pour pour nous c'était pas
difficile de le fuir ce n'était pas
difficile quand ils arrivent et vous
partiez en partant en courant en partant
au courant d'ailleurs je me raconte cet
épisode dans le livre il venait nous
chercher nous a fait monter dans une 4l
et en 2de on s'est regardés avec mon
frangin on a ouvert chacun une porte et
on a sauté en courant et on s'est sauvé
qu'à prend l'a plus revu pendant des
années ce qui s'est lassé il a fini par
se lasser
alors un jour votre maire annonce que
vous avez quitté l'est de la france pour
vous installer à narbonne et zacharias
lui il veut rester à mulhouse
parce qu'il espère devenir joueur de
hand ball professionnel et c'est une
vraie déchirure pour laisser ce départ
pour narbonne
oui c'est vrai c'est quelque chose qui
m'a marqué c'est quelque chose ce même
des années plus tard une qualité la fac
il en parlait encore avec un avec du
regret parce que il s'éclatait il était
dans un club l'as aix ptt mulhouse il
joue au handball il était reconnu il
avait le poste de pivot
il était très performant il était très
apprécié et puis le jour en un maire
nous a sorti une carte à la maison nous
a dit bon on va aller dans le sud au
soleil on va voter
on va décider ensemble quelle ville on
va choisir on a pris une carte on a
mesuré sur la carte la distance avec la
mère la plus proche c'est et narbonne
donc on a dit on va aller à narbonne en
tous les cas pour sa carrière quelque
chose se briser en gardera toujours une
certaine rancoeur vous dites dans votre
livre une certaine amertume
moi je dirais c'est comme une fêlure
petite fêlure qui vient se mettre après
une autre fêlures
je me suis rendu compte avec du recul
que n'y a pas d'élément clé il ya des
petites fêlures des plus tu marques des
coups de canifs troisième fêlures
l'arrivée à narbonne alors là c'est
terrible parce que vous êtes marocains
et vous êtes assez assez noir de peau et
vous avé l'accent alsacien
alors évidemment quand vous arrivez à
narbonne pour les gens là bas cette
espèce de martien en quelque sorte par
défaut ça fait quand vous arrivez comme
ça et que vous parlez comme ça hein
c'est pas très courant vous voyez ça
fait plutôt sourire mais voilà
maintenant quand on est adulte en
comprendre on est enfant c'est pas
quelque chose d'évident
alors il faut vous expliquer à tout le
monde la vérité il faut vous expliquez
vous êtes arabe en fait donc c'est qu'en
général on n'a pas besoin de l'expliquer
vous obligé d'expliquer ça des fois on
prend on nous prenait pour des antilles
et quand nous pourrons encore on vous
prend pour un entier qu'on est enfant
c'est ça va c'est plutôt sympathique
le contact est plutôt sympathique les
antilles le rhum la vie marine
c'est plutôt sympa et un compact qui se
fait mais comme on dit arabe maghrébin
là tout de suite ça devient plus lourd
alors adolescent vous êtes plutôt sage
parce que vous avez qu'une peur c'est
d'avoir un casier judiciaire et ne pas
pouvoir faire des études poussées
d'ailleurs à l'époque zacharias est très
très droit il dit attention il faut pas
qu'on fasse de conneries quoi exactement
crois que c'est le marque le passage à à
l'orphelinat qui nous a qu'une a fait
prendre conscience de ça qu'il fallait
qu'il fallait pas laisser passer les
opportunités de formation est depuis
très jeune c'est mon frère qui me
poussait qui me dit attention il faut
qu'on fasse des études faut pas qu'on se
laisse aller parce que dans le quartier
on habitait nos mythes et la cité
razimbaud à narbonne c'est cité hlm des
bâtiments de quatre étages une quinzaine
de blocs des terrains vagues les gamins
qui traîne qui soit dans l'hérault qui
tiennent les murs l'environnement c'est
pas un environnement créé très très
épanouissement très ouverts coincé c'est
le monde dans la stagnation
on attend que le temps passait végétatif
voilà alors côté études ça va pas si mal
mais côté familial ça s'arrange pas du
tout un jour vous promener dans la rue à
narbonne avec votre votre frère jacques
arias et il ya quelqu'un qui vous arrête
comme ça qui vous dînez vous n'êtes pas
les fils moussaoui vous alors
vous dites oui oui bien sur wii vous
connaissez notre père et l'homme vous
réponds oui j'étais en prison avec lui
notre première réaction ça a été de se
regarder et puis de regarder s'il ya des
personnes qui entendent est ce que tout
ce temps s'est sentie senti mal à l'aise
et puis tout de suite après il a demandé
des nouvelles
imaginez on fait arrêter dans la rue par
quelqu'un qui vous dit qu'il est en
prison avec votre père donc c'était
c'était quelque chose de fait une
déchirure de plus oui c'est de nouveau
un petit canif alors à ce moment là ça
va un peu mieux pour votre frère
zacharias il rencontre fanni qui est
blonde à la peau blanche et aux yeux
clairs et ils ont une histoire d'amour
qui va d'ailleurs duré dix ans mais les
parents de fannie sont à racisme
affligeant ils l'aiment pas c'est ce que
dit fanny c'est ce que disait zakaria
moi j'ai pas vu de la démonstration de
racisme virulent voyez c'était une
indifférence et comme je disais dans le
livre peut-être que fanny à a le tort de
de dévoiler les propos qui se tiennent
chez elle dans l'intimité de la maison
donc il ya un mépris qui s'est installée
une distance
au début nous vous savez quand on était
plus jeunes on pensait que les gens
racistes
c'était uniquement des gens qui
n'étaient pas cultivé que c'est les gens
qui qui qui avait peur de l'autre qui
n'avait jamais été en contact avec
l'autre au compenser que de montrer tel
qu'on est de se montrer tel qu'on était
d'essayer d'être ouvert de communiquer
d'aller vers l'autre ça faisait tomber
les barrières non non non c'est pas
aussi simple c'est plus compliqué que ça
à l'époque vous découvrez que votre
frère à carrias n'aime plus votre mère
oui c'est terrible vite qu'ils la
regardent mais pas comme on regarde une
mère il la regarde froidement avec
distance avec recul faut dire qu'ils
avaient des conflits il avait dès l'âge
de 14 ans il avait des config mais très
très dur moi je ne comprenais pas et
j'ai jamais compris sans il était
capable de de s'engueuler de se disputer
de 18h à 2h du matin c'est épuisant
surtout quand ça se passe tous les jours
parler beaucoup avec votre mère pour se
disputer apparemment mais votre mère
vous ai jamais parlé à rabat la maison
déjà je me rends compte qu'effectivement
on parlait pas arabe à la maison on
connaissait pas les gens de notre
famille on connaissait pas notre culture
on connaissait pas notre tradition le
peu de fois où on a posé des questions
par exemple quand on veut parler on veut
apprendre une langue
on a besoin d'être mis en confiance si à
chaque fois que vous voulez apprendre
une langue arabe il dit un mot de
travers ou prononcer mais on se met à
rire ça complique vénalité quoi votre
mère vous ai jamais parlé non plus de
religion la religion musulmane je
m'étais jamais été apprises ce qui a
fait que vous n'avez pas de repères en
fait c'est on était ignares on va dire
ce qui est on des ignares je dois dire
que je connaissais enfants je connais
c'est plus le catholicisme que la
religion musulmane
en alsace il n'y a pas de séparation de
l'église et de l'état
je me rappelle à l'école primaire et ben
on aller au catéchisme
moi je dis aux curés je suis musulman
mais bon à part le monde musulman je
savais pas très bien ce que ça ce qu'il
y avait derrière et puis bon il nous
racontait des histoires bon je savais
donc les gens fêter noël je savais
pourquoi j avais la toussaint je savais
pourquoi
mais le ramadan je savais pas pourquoi
la fête de la naissance du prophète
mohamed je ne savais pas pourquoi
pourquoi les gens faisaient la prière
comment il faisait la prière ne savait
pas pourquoi des ignares donc vous
fréquentez pas beaucoup d'arabes ou dit
même que votre mère était assez
xénophobe et que ce qu'elle disait dans
la bouche de français de souche sera
paris comme des propos extrêmement
xénophobe limite front national quoi
écoutez moi quand j'étais quand j'étais
plus jeune avec mon fer ça me gênait ça
nous gênait beaucoup plus ça nous gênait
beaucoup je n'avais pas peut-être les
mots pour dire si tels propos et
xénophobes ou pas mais on se sentait
très mal à l'aise pourquoi parce que dès
qu'il y avait un maghrébin c'était les
moqueries
c'était
c'était sit in nous renvoyer une image
qui est pas une image positive
donc on sentait mal à l'aise nous en
fait alors vous n'êtes pas non plus
intègre évidemment parmi les français de
souche et vous raconter dans votre livre
une anecdote assez terrible vous êtes à
mulhouse vous êtes rue kaysersberg dans
un espace vert qui est en bas de
l'immeuble où vous habitez et vous jouer
aux billes avec des petits copains en
rentrant de l'école jusqu'au jour où le
petit garçon vous dit je ne peux pas
jouer avec vous alors mes parents me
l'ont interdite alors vous dites pour ce
soir non c'est pour tout le temps
pourquoi parce que vous êtes des [ __ ]
ça c'était là notre première expérience
par un proche et c'est vrai que moi ça
ne m'est restée en mémoire parce que
c'était quelqu'un que je côtoyais
c'était quelqu'un avec qui je m'amusais
c'est quelqu'un avec qui je rigolais et
puis du jour au lendemain il ya eu ce
changement cette cassure mais ça c'est
de la gnognotte à côté de notre
expérience
alors il ya un événement important c'est
le 14 juillet 1989 vous êtes victime
d'une agression raciste à narbonne donc
quand vous courrez voir les policiers
pour chercher un abri pour qu'ils vous
protège il vous accueille avec des gaz
lacrymogènes parce que pour eux un arabe
les coupables d'office à la salle
zacharias le voit il en souffre presque
plus que vous et là aussi ça a dû faire
partie des petites fêlures qui ont tout
à fait un type qui m'arrêtent dans la
rue
il me tape sur les proches de me
retourne une ligne droite à soir de 14
juillet je m'en vais en courant au coin
de l'immeuble
je tombe sur une patrouille de police
qu'est ce que je fais le réflexe j'ai la
bouche en sang
je m'arrête je demande de l'aide puis là
il reste ils me regardent et puis le
type ils arrivent ils veulent finir
et puis un policier matraque par les
cheveux il me sort une bombe lacrymogène
et il me gaz je me semble je m'évanouis
puis j'ai la chance que de mémoire
devant un restaurant dans lequel il ya
des amis qui sont en train de dîner sont
sortis ils sont venus voir qu'est ce
qu'il y avait ils m'ont réanimer
il m'a emmené à l'hôpital et ils ont
fait ils ont fait fuir le le type mais
c'est pas c'est pas le coup de poing qui
m'a fait mal et c'est pas le coup de
poing qui m'avait révolté ce qui m'avait
révoltés à l'époque ce que j'étais jeune
j'étais un jeune homme c'est le manque
de réaction des flics français j'aime
c'est que d'accord il y avait là connu
d'accord c'était le 14 juillet d'accord
il y avait du monde mais c'est que entre
deux le choix il a évité fait forcément
c'était moi ouais et c'est vrai que
pendant longtemps j'en ai gardé un
ressentiment et pendant longtemps ça tu
es la confiance il a fallu plus
expérience plus de puces des preuves
pour relativiser alors zacharias souffre
plus que vous finalement de cette
mésaventure et puis après c'est la
guerre du golfe alors là d'un seul coup
il a le sentiment d'appartenir à l'autre
monde celui qui était attaqué par les
américains il jeudi il est je dirais on
est les étudiants et puis tout une sorte
une partie de la population parce que
moi je me rappelle les positions de jean
pierre chevènement il était il était
contre le l'attaquant en irak il ya
d'autres moyens que de bombarder des
populations civiles
maintenant il faut raison garder on
était pas on n'était pas pour saddam
hussein ah non absolument pas la
dictature le gazage des populations
kurdes on n'était pas pour ça nous ce
qu'on voyait uniquement c'était une
population civile qui allait se faire
taper dessus et en même temps que cela
on avait des gens qui il était là il
s'éclate et se répandait en en
réjouissances presque devant le mit la
grandeur et la beauté des frappes
chirurgicales qui ont fait des massacres
de populations d'un jeu vidéo comme un
jeu vidéo
les oubliés sont complètement qui
avaient des populations civiles derrière
sous les bombes c'est ce que veut éviter
notre ami mariani son sac il est parti à
bagdad alors zacharias fréquentes à ce
moment là la cafétaria de la cité
universitaire de montpellier
il rencontre des étudiants étrangers
donc il est soumis sûrement à ce
moment-là certaine influence
il part assez rapidement en angleterre
et au début il revient voir fanny tous
les 4 mois au départ il revient assez
souvent finalement mais ils commencent à
changer votre épouse fouzia ge préparent
le capes donc elle fait des études lui
lui explique un jour où il revient comme
ça qu'il faut pas que les filles phase
d'étude à petit à petit devient étranger
avoue une certaine façon au départ avec
mon épouse fusillant on comprenait pas
fouzia elle a fait des études de
biologie la fin de troisième cycle de
neuropsychopharmacologie elle préparé un
capes de biologie les années précédentes
avant qu'il parte en angleterre mon
frère était le premier à l'encourager
faut savoir que mon frère il n'avait
qu'une idée qu'une obsession c'était la
réussite professionnelle
son objectif c'était monté une
entreprise comparses de l'import export
entre les pays du maghreb les pays du
golfe et c'est pour ça qu'il était parti
en angleterre pour améliorer ses
connaissances en anglais donc quelques
mois plus tard on le voit revenir et
qu'est ce qu'on trouve dans son discours
mais pourquoi tu fais ça de toute façon
rester à la maison
c'est tu es mieux à la maison et puis de
toute façon tu sais les femmes 1 après
tout hein hein vous voyez changé alors
il se met à porter la barbe il se rase
le crâne
il commence à porter des pantalons à mi
mollet et un jour l'une de vos soeur
jamila sadi pour sortir habillé comme
comment sa vie ici et zacharias la
regarde et lui dit mais tu vas pas
sortir habillé comme une [ __ ] dire que
là vous comprenez d'un seul coup qu'il
est passé de l'autre côté on l aime à
raconter ça ça m'a fait mal au coeur et
je me suis dit qu'il y avait quelque
chose qui était vraiment brisé chez lui
moi j'ai pris ça vraiment pour vraiment
un signe de détresse alors il avait été
recruté par une secte wahhabite et vous
vous lui donnez à ce moment là des
brochures qui critiquent le wahhabisme
et et finalement au lieu de le ramener
dans le droit chemin si on peut dire ça
ça ne fait que renforcer sa
détermination je ne connaissais pas
j'étais pas du tout avertit mois par
rapport à cette secte le la secte
wahhabite où les coteaux beast j'étais
pas du tout avait retiré sa je
connaissais pas et puis
donc je savais qu'en angleterre je
lisais les journaux je savais quand même
les groupes extrémistes je savais qu'il
y avait des groupes wahhabites donc
j'allais dans une mosquée à montpellier
il y avait la documentation sur les
wahhabites je lui donne moi j'avais le
réflexe mon frère c'est un universitaire
lorsqu'il veut s'informer sur un sujet
il se fait une bibliographie
ils se constituent une documentation
donc à partir des informations que je
vais lui donner il va pouvoir avoir des
éléments pour être critique
moi c'est le raisonnement manif que
j'avais mais c'est pas comme ça qu'on
lutte contre une secte
là c'est l'échec assuré
quand on a quelqu'un qui est embrigadé
dans une secte il faut d'abord cultivée
la relation il faut cultiver les
sentiments l'attachement
car si par le coeur qu'on arrive à faire
sortir quelqu'un d'une secte
c'est pas par la raison dans un premier
temps mais la raison elle est là elle
est importante parce que quand on vient
avec les arguments et que l'on montre à
quel point le wahhabisme c'est une secte
qui est apparue il ya 250 ans et qu'on
montre à partir des arguments de la
religion que leurs propos leurs propos
d'excommunication des populations
entières leur propose de légitimation de
l'assassinât et du meurtre et que ce
sont des choses qui sont infondés qui
n'existe pas dans l'islam sunnite savoir
que les théologiens musulmans sunnites
depuis 250 ans il montre du doigt et il
met en garde contre le wahhabisme
si on montre cette réalité là là la
réaction n'est plus la même mais vous
parlez du wahhabisme comme d'une secte
la religion officielle de l'arabie
saoudite officiellement en arabie
saoudite
on appelle ça le royaume wahhabite c'est
un fait si on interroge les la
population d'arabie vont vous dire on
est en mode ali et quand l'idéologie où
habite pénètre en europe
c'est pas en disant on est noir habite
parce que nous habitent ne sont pas
aimés ils vous disent ils dit dans la
population musulmane nous sommes femmes
ben ali à dire une des quatre écoles de
jurisprudence qu'on appelle l'islam
sunnite et par cette porte là ils vont
essayer de rentrer et petit à petit ce
qu'ils vont essayer de faire c'est faire
croire à la population musulmane à la
jeunesse musulmane qu'ils sont eux les
tenants et les garants de la légalité et
de la légitimité religieuse musulmane
alors vous vous êtes sunnite
tout à fait vous êtes d'une tendance qui
s'appelle léa bâche est ce que vous nous
expliquer en quoi parce que vous savez
les français connaissent pas très bien
la deuxième religion de leur pays c'est
quand même un drame les empêche ce sont
des sunnites qui
on peut être plus pris conscience que
d'autres qu'il fallait aider la
communauté musulmane à lutter contre
l'extrémisme
le problème c'est que les wahhabites
détiennent l'argent du monde musulman et
vous dites qu'ils occupent 90 % du
linéaire islamistes en vente libre
leurs livres sont ceux qu'on trouve le
plus le plus facilement en europe
oui ça c'était c'est mais deuxième
constatation quand j'ai vu mon frère me
glisser des mains donc j'ai voulu aller
me nous renseigner me documentais qu'est
ce que j'ai fait bien le réflexe je vais
dans une librairie maghrébine
là où pour 150 francs à l'époque 150
francs on ressort avec 10 bouquin et
puis quand on discute avec le libraire
et vous apprend que en réalité les
livres ils payent pas on lui donne et on
lui dit ben tu les payes racan comme
quand tu veux je sais pas quel libraires
peuvent fonctionner comme ça donc
l'argent c'est important parce que le
fait c'est comme dans un supermarché
vous rentrez vous trouvez 80% des
linéaires qui sont remplis de
l'idéologie wahhabite économistes le
jeune kenyan france qui comme moi n'a
pas dit il n'y a pas de l'histoire n'a
pas connaissance de la culture marveaux
n'a pas de repères qu'est-ce qui va
croire il pourrait croire que c'est
représentatif du monde sunnite
alors ça n'a rien à voir est-ce que vous
pensez que les livres wahhabite
devraient être interdits à la vente en
france par exemple a tout à fait bien
sûr mais c'est pas l'unique moyen on
peut pas remplacer l'éducation c'est
c'est irremplaçable c'est une nécessité
moi je suis enseignant moi je veux le
bien moi je veux que les jeunes que je
forme au lycée ben ils soient utiles
pour eux mêmes pour leurs familles pour
la société j'ai pas envie qu'ils se
laisser embrigader par un groupe
extrémiste qui se passe sautée ou qui
tuent des gens et je voudrais que les
gens de bonne volonté
eh bien ils se révoltent ont eux aussi
dans quel sens mais qu'on sache que
derrière l'idéologie de la haine et la
terreur il ya le wahhabisme il ya
l'idéologie de seuils trop tubes et
qu'il ya des gens qui ont de l'argent et
qui pousse la vrai qu'il ya beaucoup de
zacarias moussaoui dans les banlieues
françaises
je ne sais pas mais je sais que
potentiellement il y a il ya une vraie
détresse sociale et que les wahhabites
et les adeptes de ses tubes
ils savent utiliser cette détresse
sociale pour capter les gens c'est sûr
qu'il faut un profil partie
lle c'est sûr qu'il faut être réceptif
c'est pas tout le monde mais il ya
plusieurs niveaux vous savez il ya des
rabatteurs
ce sont les adeptes de l'idéologie de
c'est trop tôt et puis après il ya ce
qui met les bombes et je sais qu'en
france il ya beaucoup de rabatteurs vous
croyez qu'en france aujourd'hui le
politiquement correct interdit de d'en
parler de ça par peur de l'amalgamé pour
éviter finalement que les gens
considèrent tous les tous les musulmans
comme des terroristes en puissance
moi je pense qu'il faudrait il faudrait
casser ce tabou et il faudrait essayer
de lancer le débat mais moi j'ai
j'apporte ma pierre vous aussi d'autres
peuvent l'apporter
et c'est clair que si on casse ce tabou
la baie les choses vont aller on va pas
refaire le monde
non mais les choses vont un peu mieux
comment ça peut aller mais alors
zacharias vous l'avais pas revu depuis
vous avez un contact avec lui depuis son
arrestation
non il m'a adressé un message dans une
de ses lettres il me disait qu'il
m'embrasser et
mise à part ça non j'ai pas eu de
contact vous pouvez parler aux états
unis parce que vous craignez d'être
gardés par les autorités américaines
jusqu'au procès comme témoin donc vous
n'y allez pas oui c'est pour ça oui
c'est pour ça ce qui est terrible avec
zacharias c'est que dans ses
déclarations il persiste et signe
dire que même maintenant où il au secret
dans une prison américaine
il n'a pas de repentir je vous fais pas
dire c'est terrible mois moi j'attends
le moment où peut-être il y aura un
recul qui sera pris par lui et il
remettra en cause un peu les idéologies
qui l'a amené là où il se trouve et où
il manifestera un repentir il attend ça
avec beaucoup d'impatience
imaginez que votre frère zacarias
moussaoui regardent cette émission est
ce que vous avez quelque chose regardez
votre caméra est ce que vous avez
quelque chose à lui dire ben moi si je
pouvais voir mon frère en face de moi je
lui dirais que tout homme tant qu'il est
vivant il a la possibilité de changer et
que c'est pas parce qu'on a fait des
erreurs dans le passé que on peut pas
être meilleure et qu' il faut avoir le
courage de reconnaître ses erreurs et
d'expliquer en quoi on a fait des
erreurs parce que dans sa situation son
cas c'est devenu un cas qui est
emblématique
et il faudrait pas qu'elle ait d'autres
qui suivent son exemple
zacarias moussaoui mon frère c'est chez
denoël impact